what are some insights you've gained
over those
five six years of autopilot about the
problem of autonomous driving so
you leaped in
having some sort of first principles
kinds of intuitions but nobody knows
how difficult
the problem like
i thought the self-driving problem would
be hard but it's it was harder than i
thought it's not like i thought it'd be
easy i thought it'd be very hard but it
was
actually way harder than than even that
so
i mean what it comes down to at the end
of the day is to solve self-driving
uh you have to solve
uh
you you basically
need to recreate
what you what humans do to drive which
is humans drive with
optical sensors eyes and biological
neural nets
um and so in order to that that's how
the entire road system is designed to
work with with uh
basically passive optical
and neural nets
um
it biologically um and now that we need
to it so for actually for full self
driving to work we have to recreate that
in digital form
um so we have to um that that means
cameras with uh
advanced uh
neural nets in silicon form
uh
and and then you it will obviously solve
for full self-driving that's the only
way i don't think there's any other way
but the question is what aspects of
human nature do you have to encode into
the machine right so you have to solve
the perception problem like detect
and then you first
realize what is the perception problem
for driving like all the kinds of things
you have to be able to see like what
what do we even look at when we drive
there's uh i just recently
heard andre talked about at mit about
like car doors i think it was the
world's greatest talk of all time about
car doors yeah um the the you know the
fine details of car doors like what what
is even an open car door man
so like the the ontology of that that's
the perception problem we humans solve
that perception problem and tesla has to
solve that problem and then there's the
control and the planning coupled with
the perception you have to figure out
like
what's involved in driving like
especially in all the different edge
cases
um
and and then i mean maybe you can
comment on this
how much game theoretic kind of stuff
needs to be involved you know at a
four-way stop sign
you know our as humans when we drive our
actions affect the world like sure it
changes how others behave most
autonomous driving if you
you're usually just responding
um to the scene as opposed to like
really um asserting yourself in the
scene do you think
i think these so i think i think these
could these sort of control control
logic conundrums are not are not the
hard part
um
the
you know
let's see um
what do you think is the hard part in
this whole
um beautiful complex problem so it's a
lot of freaking software man
a lot of smart lines of code um
uh
for sure in order to have um
create an accurate vector space uh so
like if you're you're coming from image
space which is like this this flow of
um photons you're going to camera
cameras and
and then uh
so you have this massive butt stream
um
in a in image space uh and then you have
to
effectively compress uh the
a massive
bloodstream
uh
corresponding to
photons that
knocked off an electron in a camera
sensor
uh and and turn that put stream into
into vector space um
uh by by vector space i mean like
uh
you know you've got
cars and and humans and uh
lane lines and curves and
uh
traffic lights and that kind of thing
once you uh have an accurate vector
space um the control problem is similar
to that of a video game like a grand
theft auto cyberpunk um if you have
accurate best vector space it's the
control problem is
it's i wouldn't say it's it's treble
it's not trivial but it's um
like it's it's it's it's a it's it's not
like some
insurmountable thing it's a it's but but
having accurate vector space
is very difficult yeah i think we humans
uh
don't give enough respect to how
incredible the human perception system
is to mapping the raw
photons to the vector space
representation in our heads
your brain is doing an incredible amount
of processing um
and and giving you an image that is a
very cleaned up image like when we look
around here we see like you see color in
the corners of your eyes but actually
your eyes have very few uh
uh cones like a cone receptors in the
peripheral vision your your eyes are
painting color in the peripheral vision
you don't realize it but their eyes are
actually
painting color and
your eyes also have like this blood
vessels and all sorts of gnarly things
and there's a blind spot but do you see
your blind spot no your
your brain is painting in the missing
the blind spot you're going to do these
like
see these things online where you look
look here and look at this point and and
then look at this point and it's
if it's in your blind spot it your brain
will just fill in the
the missing version the peripheral
vision is so cool yes you realize all
the illusions for vision sciences so it
makes you realize just how incredible
the brain is the rain is doing crazy
amount of post-processing on the vision
signals for your eyes
um it's insane
so um
and then and then even once you get all
those vision signals uh your
your brain is constantly trying to fig
to forget as much as possible so human
memory is
perhaps the weakest thing about the
brain is memory so because memory is
so expensive to a brain and so limited
your brain is trying to forget as much
as possible and distill
the things that you see into
uh the smallest smallest amounts of
information possible so your brain is
trying to not just get to a vector space
but get to a vector space that is the
smallest possible vector space of only
relevant objects
and i think like
you can sort of look inside your brain
or at least you know i can like when you
drive down the road
and and try to
think about what your brain is actually
doing
consciously
and it's it's conscious it's
it's
it's like
you'll see a car that's you could
because you you're you don't have
cameras you you don't have eyes in the
back your head on the side you know so
you say like
but you're you you're basically your
your head is like a
you know you basically have like
two cameras on a slow gimbal
um and and what's your
and i say it's not that great okay human
eyes are you know like um and people are
constantly distracted and thinking about
things and texting and doing all sorts
of things they shouldn't do in a car
changing radio station
so
having arguments you know is like um
so
so then like say like like
uh
like when's the last time you looked
right and left at you know or and
rearward um or even diagonally
you know forward
to actually refresh your vector space
so you're glancing around and what your
mind is doing is is is trying to distill
the relevant vectors basically objects
with a position and motion
uh
and
and and and then uh editing that down to
the least amount that's necessary for
you to drive it does seem to be able to
uh edit it down or compress it even
further into things like concepts so
it's not it's like it goes beyond the
human mind seems to go sometimes beyond
vector space
to sort of space of concepts to where
you you'll see a thing it's no longer
represented spatially somehow it's
almost like a concept that you should be
aware of like if this is a school zone
you'll remember that as a concept which
is a weird thing to represent but
perhaps for driving you don't
need to fully represent those things or
maybe you get those kind of um
well you indirectly you need to like
establish vector space and then
actually have
predictions for
uh that those vector spaces so like um
you know like if uh
you know like you drive past
say say a a
a a bus and and you see that there's
there's people
before you drove past the bus you saw
people crossing the interstate or some
just imagine there's like a large
truck or something blocking site
um
but you before you came up to the truck
you saw that there were some kids about
to cross the road
in front of the truck now you can no
longer see the kids but you you need to
be able but you would now know okay
those kids are probably gonna pass by
the truck and cross the road
even though you cannot see them so you
have to have um
memory uh
you need to remember that there were
kids there and you need to have some
forward prediction of what their
uh position will be it's a really hard
time of relevance so with with
occlusions
and computer vision when you can't see
an object anymore even it just walks
behind a tree and reappears that's a
really really
i mean at least in academic literature
it's tracking through occlusions it's
very difficult
yeah we're doing it
i understand this yeah
so some of it it's like object permanent
it's like same thing happens with the
humans with neural nets like when like a
toddler grows up like there's a there's
a point in time where
they develop they have a sense of object
permanence so before a certain age if
you have a ball
or a toy or whatever and you put it
behind your back and you pop it out if
they don't before they have object
permanence it's like a new thing every
time it's like whoa this toy went poof
disappeared and now it's back again and
they can't believe it and that they can
play peekaboo all day long because this
peekaboo is fresh every time
but then we figure out object permanence
then they realize oh no the object is
not gone it's just behind your back
um sometimes i wish we never did figure
out objective permanence
yeah so that's uh
that's an important problem to solve
yes so so
like an important evolution of the
neural nets in the car is
uh
um
memory card
memory across both time and space um so
now you can't remember like you have to
say like how long do you want to
remember things for and and it's it
doesn't there's a cost to remembering
things for a long time so you could you
know like run out of
memory to if you try to remember too
much for too long
um and and then you also have things
that are stale if if they're
remember them for too long and then you
also need things that are
remembered over time so even if you like
say have like
fragrance like five seconds of memory uh
on a time basis but like let's say you
you're parked at light and you and you
saw
you use a pedestrian example that people
were waiting to crush the
across the road and you can't you can't
quite see them because of an occlusion
uh and but they might wait for a minute
before the light changes for them to
cross the road you still need to to
remember that that that's where they
were
and that they're probably going to cross
the road type of thing
so even if that exceeds your
your your time based memory should not
exceed your space
memory
you